what we're going to do in this video is
multiply the numbers 352
and 481
and we're gonna do it in two different
ways but realize that the underlying
ideas are the same
so first let's just appreciate that 352
can be rewritten as
300
plus
50
plus 2 or we could think of it as
2
plus
50
plus 300
plus
300. you add these three numbers
together you're going to have 352.
and same idea 481 that's four hundreds
four hundreds
plus
eight tens
which is
eighty so plus eighty and then we have
one one so plus one
and you might have be familiar with
multiplying like this in the past
setting up this grid and it's
essentially we're applying the
distributive property we're going to
take the 2 and multiply it times 400
plus 80 plus 1. so we're going to
multiply 2 times each of those numbers
and actually let me just draw some quick
lines here
so we have that
and then we'll have we do it like this
then we have this
and then let me set up my grid
i'm having trouble drawing straight
lines okay there we go
and then one more in this direction
there you go and then in this direction
let me draw some horizontal lines to
have a neat clean grid here
there we go
now first we'll multiply 2 times 400
plus eighty plus one so two times four
hundred is eight hundred
two times i'm doing that same blue color
so this is eight hundred two times
eighty is a hundred and sixty and then
two times 1 is 2.
and then we can multiply 50 times these
so what's 50 times 400 well 5 times 4 is
20 and then we have another 1 2 3 zeros
so 1 2 3. so that's twenty thousand
fifty times eighty five times eight is
forty and then we have two zeros
just like that
and then we have fifty times one which
is of course going to be equal to fifty
and then we go to the 300 which we will
distribute and multiply times each of
these each of these numbers 300 times
400 3 times 4 is 12 and then we have
four zeros one two three four
we get a hundred twenty thousand three
hundred times eighty 3 times 8 is 24 and
then we have one two three zeros one two
three so we get twenty four thousand and
then three hundred times one is of
course equal to three hundred and then
what we wanna do is add up all of these
numbers so let's actually add up the
rows first
so if we add up the rows let me draw
another
line going straight down like that
and so if we sum this up this is going
to be 962. 800 plus 160 is 960 plus two
so this is 962.
this right over here is 24 050
24
050
and then this right over here is what a
hundred and a hundred and forty four
thousand three hundred one hundred forty
four thousand and three hundred hundred
twenty thousand plus twenty four
thousand is hundred forty four thousand
plus three hundred there you have it and
then you would add up these numbers just
like that to get your final answer and
i'm going to hold off doing that for a
second as we see the other way of
multiplying these numbers so the other
way of doing it we could have said
400
and this is sometimes called the
standard algorithm
481 times
350.
we do the same colors
352
and in the standard algorithm the way
that we do it is we start
with this 2 in the ones place and then
we multiply it times 481 so 2 times 1 is
2
2 times 8 is 16.
so we put the 6 here and then we
sometimes we'll say we'll carry the 1.
we're really regrouping that as the
hundreds that's 10 tens which is the
hundreds and then 2 times four
is eight which is really eight hundred
plus one so that's nine or really nine
hundred do you see a pattern here this
962 is the exact same thing as that 962
right over there why well because we
multiplied the 200 times the 1 times the
80 times the 400 we saw that over here
and then we just added them all together
to be 962. that's all the standard
algorithm did just now and then we move
over to the five but this is really five
tens or 50 and that's why in the
standard algorithm we put a zero here
before that before saying all right
what's 5 times 1 it's 5.
what's 5 times 8 it is 40 we regroup the
four let's delete this from before
what's 5 times 4 well that's 20 plus 4
is 24.
notice 24 050 that's exactly what we had
over here and it makes sense because
we're taking a 50 and we're multiplying
it times 4 481 which is exactly what we
did right over there and so you might
guess what's going to happen when we
take this 3 and we multiply it times 481
that's really a 300 times 481 let me
delete that so i don't get confused
so
because it's a 300 in the standard
algorithm we put two zeros here first
when i say algorithm it just means a
method of doing something
and so we'll say 3 times 1 is 3 3 times
8 is 24
and then 3 times 4 is 12 plus 2 is
14.
and so notice i have forty four thousand
three hundred
and the standard way of doing it at this
point we just add them all up so whether
we're doing it here or here we just add
everything up so two plus zero plus zero
is two six plus five is eleven
regroup that one so one plus nine plus
three is thirteen
and then one plus four plus four is nine
two plus four is six and we have a one
right over there so we get a hundred
sixty nine thousand
three hundred and twelve and so when you
just learn this method the standard
algorithm we some people might call it
it might seem like hey this just seemed
like a little bit of a magic but all
you're doing is you're going to each of
these places and you're distributing it
you're multiplying it times 400 plus 80
plus 1 to get this then you're
multiplying 50 times 400 plus 80 plus 1
and then 300 times 400 plus 80 plus 1
exactly what we did right over here